ليه اليوم الثالث على التوالي يستمر الجدل
حول مشاهد الاعتداءات التي تعرض لها طاقم
التمريض في مستشفى قويسنا العام وزير
الصحه توجه للمستشفى والتقى الطاقه الطبيه
والتمريضي واكد ان القضيه قيد التحقيق
وانه لا احد فوق القانون احد الذين صوره
وهم يقومون بالاعتداءات يعمل كباب الطيار
المتحدث العسكري اصدر بيانا اعلن فيه ان
القوات المسلحه تتابع ما اثر عن القضيه
وتؤكد كامل احترامها لسياده القانون وتهيب
الجميع تحري الدقه وانتظار انتهاء
التحقيقات وفي منزلها التقينا بالسيده مها
بشر احدى الممرضات المعتدى عليهم حيث اكدت
انها هي وزميلاتها تعرضنا للاهانه وانهن
يطالبان بالعدل وانهن في انتظار انتهاء
التحقيقات والتضحي كافه الحقائق بعيدا عن
الشائعات التي انتشرت على صفحات مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
احنا عايزين حقنا لهنا اللي احنا ديت
عايزين حقنا ردي اعتبار دي اشاعات فيس في
صور اللي نزل الكلام ده ما فيش زميلتنا
مفيش حد عندنا حامل ما فيش حد عندنا سيت
احنا مفيش حد هنا حامل
التقينا باحدى الممرضات التي طالبت بضروره
توفير الحمايه للتواقم الطبيه من مثل هذه
الاعتداءات
يعني مش مش طالعين الاهانه
الاخيره شهد التطورات جديده بعد ظهور
الفيديوهات وتصريحات من اسره الطيار تشير
الى ان بعد افراد المستشفى هم بداروا
بالاعتداءات على المريضه واسرتها احنا
قدام روايتين واحنا دلوقت قدام جهتين
تحقيق النيابه العسكريه بيتحقق والنيابه
العامه بيتحقق في انتظار التحقيقات
الرسميه لاعلان النتائج والان يبقى الجميع
في انتظار انتهاء التحقيقات من كافه
الاطراف لكشف الحق وحسم الجدل ومعاقبه
المتسببين في واقعه اعتداءات مستشفى
قويسنا العام التي شغلت الراي العام احمد
عثمان العربيه مدينه قويسنا محافظه
المنوفيه